cover my right honorable friend the
paymaster general make a statement on
the impartiality of the Civil Service in
light of the proposed appointment of the
second permanent Secretary of the
department for leveling up housing and
communities as Chief of Staff to the
leader of the opposition
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker
I can confirm that following a media
report the previous day uh sugray
formerly second permanent secretary at D
Larkin at the cabinet office resigned
for the Civil Service on Thursday the
2nd of March this resignation was
accepted with immediate effect
on Friday the 3rd of March a statement
from the opposition announced that the
labor party had offered Sue gray the
role of Chief of Staff to the leader of
the opposition
the house will recognize that this is an
exceptional situation
it is unprecedented for a serving
permanent secretary to resign to seek to
take up a senior position working for
the leader of the opposition
as honorable members will expect the
cabinet office is looking into the
circumstances leading up to sue Gray's
resignation in order to update the
relevant Civil Service leadership and
Ministers of the facts
subsequent for that I will update the
house appropriately
by way of background to inform honorable
members there are four pertinent set of
rules and guidance for civil servants in
relation to this issue
first
under the civil service code every civil
servant is expected to uphold the civil
services core values which include
impartiality
the code States civil servants must act
in a way that deserves and retains the
confidence of ministers
secondly
for very senior civil servants rules
apply when they wish to leave the
service permanent secretaries are
subject to the business appointments
process which for most senior leavers is
administered by a cobra the advisory
committee on business appointments
they provide advice to the Prime
Minister who is the ultimate decision
maker in cases of the most senior civil
servants
once prime minister has agreed the
conditions and the appointment is taken
up okober publishes the letter to the
applicant on their website
the business appointment rules form part
of civil servants contracts of
employment
the rules state
that approval must be obtained prior
to a job offer being announced
the cabinet office has not as yet been
informed that the relevant notification
to a cobra has been made
thirdly civil servants must follow
guidance on the Declaration of
management of outside interests they are
required on an ongoing basis to declare
and manage any outside interests which
may give rise to an actual or perceived
conflict of interest
finally the directory of civil service
guidance States the contact between
senior civil servants and leading
members of the of opposition parties
should be cleared with ministers
having set out the relevant rules Mr
Speaker let me finish by saying that
regardless of the details of the
specific situation
I understand why members of this house
and eminent commentators outside have
raised concerns
the impartiality and perceived
impartiality of the Civil Service is
constitutionally vital to the conduct of
the government
and I'm certain all senior civil
servants are acutely aware of the
importance of it being maintained
ministers must be able to speak to their
officials from a position of absolute
Trust and so it is the responsibility of
everyone
in this house to preserve and support
the impartiality of the Civil Service
Mr Speaker to Echo my white honorable
friends comments many of us are indeed
prized and frankly deeply disappointed
about the particular circumstances that
have emerged this is not about the
character or quality of Sue gray having
had the pleasure of working with her
over a number of years I can testify
along with many others to those
qualities this is as my right honorable
friend has said about an issue of
fundamental trust that has to exist
between impartial civil servants up to
the highest level and here we are
dealing with a permanent secretary Mr
Speaker and the ministers whom they
serve that has been the position since
at least the Northcote trevellian report
of the mid 19th century and must be be
the position in future particularly if
the party opposite is serious about
wishing to achieve power and if this
government isn't prepared to defend that
impartiality then the activities of the
lead of the opposition might suggest
that he is not prepared to defend yeah
I'm grateful to my right honorable
friend for clarifying the position with
the application to akaba will he confirm
the disappointment if indeed it is to be
taken up cannot be taken up until it is
formally approved following advice from
that committee and secondly is it
correct that the prevailing acaba advice
for civil servants has a potential
waiting period of between three months
and indeed up to two years thirdly will
a lobbying prohibition be imposed in
this case and finally will a restriction
on the passage of official information
to the party opposite be imposed in this
instance I say again Mr Deputy speaker
trust and impartiality
if this system of government is to work
I would hope that in this case those
issues will be defended
I thank my right-honorable learner
friend I share his disappointment
and whatever the merits with the
individual I would stress
that it is critical that we all on both
sides of the house to all we can to
support the impartiality of the Civil
Service
he asks three points in particular
um whether there's a three month to a
two-year period uh he is right there's
also the ability of Cobra can recommend
that no such point will be appropriate
it can go further but there's a standard
three-month awaiting period uh in the uh
term in the contracts of employment for
permanent secretaries akobo generally
goes up to two years but it can go
further there is a lifetime requirement
on all civil servants uh which I know
they take hugely seriously of respecting
the confidentiality of the work that
they do it is right that that is in
place uh and lastly
um akoba is an advisory position uh I I
have not been impressed by the labor
party over this Saga I trust that the
labor party would indeed follow
recommendations from a cobra I unless
they're going to podcast even more even
more doubt on their credibility
Shadow leader of the labor party Angela
Rayner
thank you Mr Speaker I'd also like to
thank members opposite for asking why a
senior civil servant famed for their
integrity and dedication to Public
Service decided to join the party with a
real plan for Britain rather than Mr
Speaker a tired out washed up sleaze
addicted Tory government
this is the exceptional circumstances
that the minister spoke about a party so
self-obsessed that they are using
parliamentary time to indulge in the
conspiracy theories of the former prime
minister and his guns what will they ask
for next a Westminster Hall debate on
the moon landings the bill of dredging
the Loch Ness or Republic inquiry into
whether the Earth is flat
the biggest threat to the impartiality
of the Civil Service is the party
opposite and
dedicate decade of debasing and
demeaning public standards in public
life and they talk about trust Mr
Speaker this debate says more about the
delusions of the modern conservative
party than it does about anything else
and after this question Mr Speaker I'll
go back to my office to help people
struggling with the cost of living
crisis getting an NHS dentists
foreign
I don't think that was a wise idea to
carry on when I'm stood up
thank you can I just say I expect
everybody to heard
quietly because I want to hear what's
been said is too important not for me to
hear and when you keep tuning on that
color here so I want the same respect to
everyone who wishes to speak Angela
thank you Mr Speaker as I was saying
after this question I'll go back to my
office to help people struggling with
the cost of living getting an NHS
dentist and paying their energy bills
all of which is a result of 13 years of
this failed conservative Administration
while
there's Mr Speaker we're getting on with
tackling the real issues facing the
country when will they do the same
[Applause]
well Mr Speaker having heard from the
right honorable lady
she's clearly been advised that attack
is the best form of Defense I quite
understand why they feel in need of some
more advisors and some new advisors
given her tone today I I understand the
Dilemma faced by the leader of the
opposition having looked inside his tent
having looked inside his tent I
understand why he's reaching so far
outside it
after so many rebrands I appreciate why
the right honorable lady and the leader
of the opposition require someone who
can do joined up but let me just say
this
the party opposite talks about rules
they talk about transparency they talk
about standards in public life
given all the constant talk it's time
they walked the walk
yeah
so I asked the right honorable lady to
go away and think were they why are they
refusing to publish when they met with
Sue gray why why are they being evasive
why can't they tell us what they
discussed where they met how often they
met their refusal to do so begs the
question
exactly what is labor trying to hide
[Music]
many across the house have noticed that
the leader of the opposition has a
tendency to claim a self-righteous
Monopoly on morals but there are now
serious questions as to whether labor by
acting fast and loose undermined the
rules and the impartiality of a civil
service
those opposite must ask themselves why
did the leader of the opposition
covertly meet with a senior civil
servant and why were those meetings not
declared they believe a cobra rules
should be tightened but why weren't the
current ones followed
it is incumbent on everyone across the
house to uphold and preserve the
integrity and the perceived impartiality
of the Civil Service this is about trust
Mr Speaker
and into the labor party the risks
damaging that trust with an offer of
appointment
but the labor party can help restore
that trust
they can do the right thing
they can publish the list of meetings
between themselves and Sue gray
they can publish who attended those
meetings and publish when they started
speaking to sugray
because there is nothing in their Cobra
rules that stops I'm doing so today
chair of the select committee William
ragg thank you Mr Speaker can I say how
heartened I am to see the chamber so
well attended for a cabinet office
urgent question on matters of
constitutional propriety yeah yeah it
hasn't always been been like that in
here now can I say Mr Speaker on a
personal note I I would consider this
appointment to be somewhat ill-judged
and I think those who are of reasonable
mind on all sides of this argument would
accept that but can I ask my uh right on
your friend if he shares my confidence
in our Noble friend Lord pickles and his
committee the advisory committee on
business appointments to discharge its
functions correctly and I wonder also
has he uh any more thoughts about making
a cobra rulings uh underpinned in
statute and uh just just to end though
Mr Speaker I think it's important to say
given the individual at the heart of
this does he share my concern that it is
wrong to impugn an entire Civil Service
of political bias and that is important
that he asserts that from the dispatch
box
for this time starting with if I may uh
Mr Speaker the most important point
which my honorable friend made uh
absolutely uh to back up his point on
the uh the standards of the Civil
Service uh I believe we are lucky and
fortunate to have good people working
throughout the Civil Service I know that
a large number of them will be very uh
concerned uh by these events because
they know the critical importance of
that Bond of trust between a minister
and their most senior advisors I I
totally uh respect uh the work of a
cobra and uh all of uh the committee I
know that they will uh that they will
consider their processes they will go
through this thoroughly and uh that the
uh the Prime Minister will injure due
course receive their advice on The Wider
Point honorable friend makes uh clearly
the government has received uh uh
recommendations from his own committee
from pakak from Synergy Boardman and
from the committee of standards in
public life uh a process is well
Advanced for coming up with a government
response to that and I expect to be
sharing that with the house at India
course we now come to SMP spokesperson
Kirsten plan thank you very much Mr
Speaker crew I'm glad to hear the
minister talking about the hard work
that the Civil Service do and being
clear in a game with his colleague and
that the ministers and secretaries of
state would be nowhere were it not for
the constant hard work of the impartial
civil servants and it's very important
that the minister talks to his back
bench colleagues and ensures that in
making statements about individuals they
are not
um tarring the entire civil service with
some of the allegations that they are
and bringing forward Mr Speaker I've
asked repeatedly um about
anti-corruption Champions and while we
are standing here talking about um
issues that relate to breaches of the
ministerial code or potential breaches
of the ministerial code it is incredibly
important the government gets its house
in order and and ensures that we have an
anti-corruption champion in place will
the minister therefore both talk to his
back bench colleagues to ensure that
their language is moderated when they
are talking about civil servants and
also ensure that the ministerial code is
adhered to that
um in order that um we can be viewed in
a better light internationally
yeah minister
uh Mr speaker thank you I thank you for
a question the anti-corruption strategy
is run by my right honorable friend the
minister for security I know he works
actively on that I know that
anti-corruption champion will be
appointed in due course I had to say it
is uh in in deference The Honorable
position I think that's a very different
scenario from what we're talking about
uh today uh I think we're talking about
this little service code for a start uh
not the ministerial code and I think but
I do agree with her that we need to
always support and not undermine the
impartiality and the perceived
impartiality of the Civil Service that
applies to all of us including the
leader of the opposition
Sir William cash
um is my right honorable friend aware as
to whether or not a contract has been
entered into between the parties
concerned written or Unwritten because
this important question raised by my
right honorable friend raises not only
questions of constitutional propriety
but and not only questions of
impartiality but also matters relating
to confidentiality between the person's
concerned
and furthermore I'd like to know whether
there is any question of any involvement
of taxpayers money as part of these
arrangements as being part of the short
money which will be involved in the in
the office of the leader of the
opposition
I I thank all right from a friend uh the
uh as he will appreciate I I am in no
position
to to know whether there is a contract
either oral or written uh between two
gray and the labor party nor am I in any
position to judge how her fugitive post
if it was to go through would be funded
they are both questions that can only be
answered on the other side of the house
it would be in the interest of
transparency and Clarity were those to
be cleared up along with the timeline of
events as to when these meetings started
who took part and where they took place
thank you thank you Mr Speaker On
impartiality Mr Speaker Sue gray has
resigned and I can assure the right
honorable gentleman that she was just as
Resolute in seeking to protect standards
in public life and the ministerial code
when I was a minister as he has tried to
be under this conservative government
and aren't her professionalism and
integrity just what Britain needs after
the the debasement absolute big basement
of our standards in public life in the
last 13 years
foreign
I'm deliberately not getting drawn into
uh matters on individuals uh Mr Speaker
nor should I be
Amazon what I am happy to be drawn on
though is whether there is a right way
of making these kind of appointments
this is an unprecedented appointment uh
offer of appointment it is totally
unprecedented at a permanent secretary
level this is not as far as I'm aware
ever been undertaken before and it's
incredibly important in those
circumstances that the rules are
followed appropriately we are checking
to make certain what exactly uh was the
run-up to her resignation Jacob respond
Mr speaker now many people may say that
Miss gray is a splendid woman and I
understand she even fed the cats in the
cabinet office but does this not smash
the pieces the idea of an independent
Civil Service when we know that one of
the most senior civil servants in the
country was conniving in secret meetings
with the party of opposition and does
this not
undervalue years of advice and reports
that she has given her views on
Devolution which were known constantly
to be soft her report into the right
honorable member the member for Uxbridge
which we now know was done by a friend
of the Socialist does this not undermine
all her previous word and the ideal
independence of a servant can I just
remind them just sit
laughs
can I just say to them I did say I don't
want anybody creeping into the report I
know you're careful but it's just the
marker I don't want it's a creeping
Feast right let's just move on to the
minister to reply thank you Mr Speaker
um
I will
two points to make to my uh right
honorable friend uh the first is we need
to make certain this does not damage the
impartiality or the perceptions of
impartiality of the Civil Service as a
whole my right honorable friend would
I'm sure agree that that is incredibly
important and we need to ensure we need
to ensure that that's retained and I I'm
deeply worried that the approach made by
the labor party has may serve to
threaten and to put at risk those with I
apologize I'd put that at risk I would
also say uh that the um uh I think I
will leave it at that we mustn't tarnish
the whole civil service by one
appointment but it is the opposition
playing fast and loose with a set of
rules designed to protect the
impartiality of that civil service that
we all know is so important
constitutionally for our country not in
cowens
conservatives demanding that labor
observe the recommendations of acaba who
in previous conservative chancellors and
foreign secretaries bypass the process
before taking up appointments and we
have Labor stretching the process to
breaking point where operating in the
shadows is it time that we give actor by
some teeth
hmm
I Thank The Honorable question the uh my
writing friend the prime minister is
considering uh proposals made by pakak
uh by the committee standards in public
life and by Sir Nigel Boardman about how
we could improve the business
appointments process uh I think there is
a lot of sympathy that we should be
looking at those rules and we will be
reporting uh to the house on how they
could be uh how they could be amended or
improved I do think it's an irony though
that the opposition has consistently
called those rules to be tightened but
they don't seem to be quite aware of
what the rules or may not be fully aware
of what the rules are today
Simon Hall
speaker the response of the Civil
Service to this issue I think amplifiers
have underscores to all of our comfort
the importance which they attach to
their impartiality to serve Ministers of
the crown irrespective of which color
base down for elections under but could
I Echo what I think is a growing theme
LED Aid in The Honorable friend member
for Hazel Grove
for the committee to put the
recommendation to the Prime Minister
that puts the Prime Minister always but
particularly in this case
in a very invidious position if he says
no he looks churlish if he says yes
he makes the Civil Service already
anxious by the attack on their
impartiality still more anxious an iot
my right honorable friend to speed up
the process of response to the
suggestions which have been made to
formalize the recommendations of the
committee yeah minister
well I thank my honorable friend for the
uh for the question uh as I said I've
already said what I've said regarding uh
the government considering uh how the
business Department's procedures could
be uh improved I I do have a lot of uh
faith in the akoba process uh in law
pickles and his uh committee and I know
we look forward to him looking through
this process uh uh Sue gray will put
through her application or if that's the
combinational process I presume that
that is uh happening
um and they will need to take a decision
on the base of it and then provide uh
advice Andrew Gwynn thank you the faux
outrage and wild conspiracies from the
party opposite are kidding nobody yeah
can I remind the minister of the words
of a predecessor of his as cabinet
office Minister the noble Lord Maude who
said that he worked with suit gray for
five years and I quote Mr Speaker never
have the slightest reason to question
either her Integrity or her political
impartiality and went on to add that the
leader of the opposition is and I quote
fortunate to have secured her Services
yeah he's right isn't it
minister
well I'm I'm gladly the uh
the old Redmond obviously knows Co
outrage when he sees it he's a long
experience of it
I'm grateful for reminding me of the
words of my predecessor as uh MTO and as
indeed has been problem for uh for
Horsham on I too have had the the uh I
do have worked with with Sue gray I've
uh admired her advice and uh and I have
had no reason to question uh her
Integrity that doesn't mean however that
this has been the way we should conduct
these kind of circumstances I think I'm
very disappointed I'm very disappointed
in the actions of the labor party I'm
very disappointed in how this has gone
through and I think there are real
concerns about the impact that may have
on the perceptions of impartiality more
broadly so John wittingdale
all right friend aware that I like many
members here was advised by Sue gray on
my appointment as a minister on the
steps that I needed to take in order to
avoid any perception of potential
conflict of interest and does she there
does he therefore understand
why her appointment has caused such
anger right across this Civil Service as
it undermines that very principle of the
perception of conflict
uh I I I do my right on the friend is
right to draw upon the fact that her
many senior civil servants are are
troubled by this they know the vital
importance of that Bond of trust between
ministers and civil servants and
anything that might serve to undermine
it uh is not healthy but it's not good
for the way we do business
is speaker you like I have been
experienced members of this house and I
and I understand also that very early on
in your remarks you've rumbled what was
going on in terms of the number of
requests for this for this to be debated
this morning isn't it the fact that this
is a Shabby little maneuver from the
shabbiest government that I think
can I just ask that rather this this
being spontaneous I was on Earth walking
over here with a respected back venture
from the government side who said I'm
not going over they've been trying to
get everyone here this morning the whips
are on a five-line whip
[Applause]
the civil service is up in arms is
nonsense this comes from the prime
minister
order
[Applause]
I'm not sure there was a question
in which case we'll move on so somewhere
thank you Mr Speaker the whole situation
surrounding this appointment is quite
extraordinary and many will say it is
outrageous does my white honorable
friend agree with me that appointing
such a senior and high profile civil
servant into this post under such
circumstances is questionable and just
the right number friends agree with me
that what is of deep concern is the
timing of disappointment when she was
approached and where meetings were held
the details must be published
I believe transparency would help it's
an answer to my honorable friend uh that
uh it's important that processes are
followed because this is an
unprecedented appointment but in those
circumstances it is not too much to ask
for the meetings to be published who met
whom when where what was discussed uh
the points raised by my right audible
friend uh the uh member for
um uh the Marvel friend it is absolutely
right uh that they do go through this
and that the labor party publishes
exactly what took place Sammy Wilson
speaker the impartiality of senior civil
servants has been called in the question
a long time ago during the brexit debate
and the events subsequent to that but
these negotiations obviously didn't take
place the morning after Sue gray
resigned they've been going on for some
time and I suppose a question for this
house is what sensitive political issues
was she involved in during those
negotiations and will the minister agree
with me that no amount of Bluster from
the front bench will ever hide the
double standards of lecturing about
accountability and and transparency well
at the same time not being prepared to
answer a straightforward question as to
when they started talking to sue Gray
I think the honorable gentleman puts it
rather well it would be very simple just
to help put Minds at Rest by publishing
the data just setting out when the
meetings took place who met whom when
and where that will help reassure the
house it won't reassure the house
completely but at least there'll be
proper transparency and some more
clarity Richard Drex
thank you Mr Speaker this is about
impartiality and trust and it saddens me
to see the deputy leader of the labor
party such a senior position defending
this in the way that she did
if if the rules have not been followed
at a lengthy period of time has not
succumbed I.E two years
Sue gray has had access to highly
confidential and very personal
information she is in a very powerful
position to use this not just with
anyone but with the opposition party and
with a general election looming
yeah
um
The Honorable gentleman is correct The
Honorable friend is correct uh that
there is clearly sugray has access to a
lot of information that does not mean
that she would put the information to
Ill use but the acober guidelines talk
about sensitive information and how you
can avoid the perception that we've been
put into a difficult position in those
circumstances so Cobra has obviously got
a job to do
thank you Mr Speaker
which
Bond of trust or aspect of impartiality
was broken when Sue gray was a senior
civil servant the same Sue gray that was
praised by the government almost the
best thing since sliced bread what's
what's the problem what's the issue now
we are conducting
analysis to find out the facts uh to
ensure that the facts that led up to the
resignation of uh sugray can be sent out
it would help dispel concerns and
worries and problems if the labor party
could simply set out the facts
themselves and there is no reason why
they couldn't do that today
Dr Matthew
Mr Speaker the permanent secretary at
the department for Education recently
highlighted the detail of the civil
service code to all her staff she said
that if anybody received contact from
the leader of the opposition or a member
of The Shadow cabinet you should tell
your permanent secretary right away
is the minister aware when Sue gray
informed her permanent Secretary of the
initial discussion she held the labor
party before announcing her resignation
okay minister
as I say there is a work in progress to
ensure that all the facts are absolutely
identified but I'm not aware that there
are any such discussions prior to uh the
Thursday of last week
Wayne David
Mr Speaker not that long ago the
advisory committee on business
appointments
phone that the former member for Abba
kunwi a former Defense Minister
committed a clear breach of the
ministerial code by not asking for
aquaba advice when taking up a position
Now calendar Minister indicate and
remind us what actions were taken
against a former member for Abercrombie
for a bridge that was this guy's
described at the time as totally
unacceptable what do they do
look at this there
I'm The Honorable gentleman refers to a
former member of this house the former
Minister and a former member of the
conservative party I think he had the
withdrawn at that stage I don't know
what actions the Cobra took a cobra is
and I didn't I don't think what actions
are available to them because the Cobra
is
an advisory body however I think it
beholds all of us who wish to respect
the values of impartiality within the
Civil Service and respect the rules to
ensure that we follow them to the letter
Steve Brown so I think it's an important
urgent question this desired appointment
just just there's something about it
doesn't feel right to me and to Echo the
chair the select committee who's no
longer in his place I don't think it
passes the the reasonable test but we
are where we are for now although I
expect there's a lot more to come on
this the minister confirmed that the
cabinet office are looking at the
circumstances of the job offer can he
just say when we might expect that to be
complete and will he be asking Sue gray
herself who of course has every interest
in transparency the who met who when and
where question minister
uh the uh we will be trying to wrap this
up as soon as we can correct answer to
my uh honorable friend
um I don't know how long it will take
hopefully shortly but it would ease that
process if the labor party would just
come clean with us exactly what meetings
took place there's no reason why this
should not be made public why we should
not be fully transparent at least no
reason of which I am aware at Western
speaker I don't know Sue Gray
by virtue of her reputation but
by virtue of her reputation but I do
weigh on the words of Lord Maude that we
heard just a moment ago that she is a
person of utmost decency exactly I'm
aware of the various civil servants who
joined this place as members of
parliament for all sides
um
and therefore I'm surprised really at
the concern from the government benches
because this is a person of the utmost
integrity and given the high esteem in
which he has held why does he think the
right honorable member for Uxbridge
never considered appointing him
I look I
as I said earlier I'm not trying to uh
engage in a discussion about a
particular individual I've noted what uh
my predecessor Lord Maude uh said and as
I say I've had personal direct
experience of working with Sue gray and
whilst doing so I had no reason in any
way to uh to question her Integrity but
this uq is about that process we need to
understand this is an unprecedented
appointment of a permanent secretary to
this position it is incredibly important
when you have very senior civil servants
uh if they choose to to leave the
service that everything is followed
appropriately that is what the analysis
is undertaking that is what we want
those are the facts that we need to
establish it would help if the labor
party would help us in that process
James Wilde
what
Mr Speaker
um does my does the minister agree with
me that if the shoe was on the other
foot the labor path you'd be asking
exactly the same questions
[Applause]
that somehow his most senior advice in
Chief of Staff wouldn't have a role in
the general election campaign it's
utterly ridiculous
[Applause]
I I think uh I think my honorable friend
uh makes a good point I've done a number
of urgent questions in this house I've
rarely seen the opposition benches as
empty as they are today
Amy Callahan
thank you Mr Speaker
why are this government happy to attack
several servants with this urgent
question you're unwilling to pay them
properly
Minister
um to be clear Mr Speaker there is no
desire whatsoever or intention to attack
civil servants on this side of the house
none whatsoever what this side of the
house wants to do is to ensure that we
protect the impartiality of the Civil
Service that we protect it from any
shift in the perceptions of the
impartiality of the Civil Service and
that we hold the opposition to account
to actually be a bit more transparent
about their dealings Jonathan goddess
thank you Mr Speaker the leader of the
opposition was best friends with the
member for Islington North and as soon
as he lost the election dumped him he
was Pro a second referendum lost the
election dumped it had 10 pledges to
become leader of the opposition dumped
it a Rebrand after Rebrand this is a
labor party with a grubby deal clearly
going on behind the scenes here Mr
Speaker the league opposition talks
about integrity openness and honesty so
why can't he evaluate all those three
things and tell us who where when and
why
I very much agree that uh with an
honorable friend that those are
questions that need to be answered
and they need to be answered by that
side of the house at least Cunningham Mr
Speaker I don't know how familiar the
minister is with
maths back out of your eye when all the
whale there's a plank in your own eye
contrary to what the minister said this
move is not without precedent so James
Sassoon a senior civil servant on the
same grade as Sue gray resigned on the
same month that Lehman Brothers collapse
only to join George Osborne as his
economic adviser three weeks later and
in time became a Tory government
Minister well the minister confirmed
that appointment and correct the record
Minister
I I I I I can't recall
um that particular appointment I regret
to tell uh The Honorable gentleman I uh
though there are uh there are other
appointments the the which I can I can
think of but none none where the
individual concern had such a prominent
role in government at the center of
Affairs as a center of Affairs at the
center of Affairs inside the cabinet
office and in this case inside uh d-luck
I understand why people inside this
house and outside want to ensure that
processes have been correctly followed
yeah come to their back door
the damage has already been done the
minister keeps on saying what impact
this will have on the civil service but
it already has had an impact and away
from this it might also be noted that
Sue gray was chairing the infected blood
inquiry in which many of us in this
house have written to various ministers
to see if we can get answers what now is
the state on that very needed and
necessary inquiry
uh the the
um my older friend raises an excellent
question that Sue grade was actually the
sponsor uh to the uh Inquirer inside the
cabinet office uh I'm uh looking forward
to meeting uh members of the infected
and affected Community uh tomorrow uh
sugray had an incredibly important role
in corralling that across uh government
uh we will need to fill that post I've
not been able to do so to date it is a
matter of huge priority to me it
requires an awful lot of work and there
are very very serious Stakes James shell
thank you Mr Speaker can I thank the
minister for his answers
it doesn't Minister accept that
impartiality is not just a desirable
cruelty but is also an essential
quilting for any investigation those
Minister believe that the test for
impartiality were met in this case
before any news of their jobs had
emerged
minister
I thank my uh on the algorithm for uh
his question uh I I don't want to
pre-charge for the analysis of the facts
clearly a cobra have got to do uh their
work as well and come to a conclusion
and I'm sorry to repeat myself to The
Honorable gentleman but uh more clarity
as to what happened when uh really would
help speed up that process
thank you Mr Speaker and I confess to
feeling a little sorry for the deputy
leader of the labor party because she
has been sent out here today to defend
the in defense
[Music]
[Applause]
knowledge not only of some of those
sensitive policy making knowledge but
also the legitimate personal interest of
ministers and it is for those very good
reasons that uh we uh we should afford
this decision today can I agree with my
right I'm a friend about the importance
of establishing the dates on which these
meetings which undoubtedly would have
taken weeks if not months uh uh to take
place but also can I ask whether he will
consider amending the senior civil
service contracts as well as the civil
service code to prevent future such
occurrences because this is something
which strikes at the core of the
Integrity of the Civil Service yeah
minister oh I thank my honorable friend
uh there are there is work undergoing
being undergone at the moment uh looking
at uh our conclusions that we draw from
uh the work done by Sinatra Boardman by
pakak and by the committee on standards
in public life I wouldn't wish to
preempt any of those discussions I don't
know in all Candor the moral friend
whether that is something which has been
uh considered
um but uh I I will there'll be a further
opportunity in this house when we come
forward uh with our uh proposed uh
reforms in due course of such matters to
be raised vital fabriclet
yeah
I mean is it not ironic that Sue gray
was the head of the cabinet officer's
proprietary and ethics team and it is
her who has put the Civil Service under
a dark shadow a shadow which need not
have existed and is it also not the case
that this therefore was bad judgment by
her but also bad judgment by the leader
of the opposition who when asked ten
times this morning to give more
information as to when discussions began
ten times he evaded minister
um I've had my honorable friend I I
think it may well have been a
miscalculation by the leader of the
opposition uh he can do his best to
rescue that by being fully open about
the facts
Nigel Adam
civil servants in my time as a minister
in those relationships are built on
trust and I've also had a very good
working relationship with uh Sue gray in
the cabin office
but does the minister agree with me that
this appointment by the leader of the
opposition is not only politically naive
I mean it it's hard enough for ministers
not knowing which of their WhatsApp
messages are going to be leaked the
journalists uh by members of your own
size
um but what surely disappointment
um now places all civil servants working
uh with ministers in a very difficult
position in terms of trust and
impartiality
when he says he has a good working
relationship with Sue gray I know he
speaks for many ministers me uh included
and I see other right honorable
gentlemen shaking and nodding their
heads in in agreement with that uh
phrase but that makes it all the more
shocking that fast and loose approaches
can be taken it appears to me to the
rules and that that can therefore bring
into doubt the really important
relationships of trust that exist
between ministers and civil servants
it's so important as a right honorable
gentleman knows it's so important for
the way we do business and I think
people should think very very carefully
before they do risk doing anything that
might call that into question or
jeopardize that incredibly important
relationship
thank you Mr Speaker I care very deeply
about this place
and we've been plunged into a
constitutional crisis
members of this house whether they're
ministers or not need to be able to talk
to senior civil servants without fear
that that information is going to be
used for party political purposes
it's done Med damage Mr Speaker
to the Civil Service and I don't know if
he'll be able to recover
but the it's not about
Sue Gray
it's about the leader of the opposition
we would not be here today if he hadn't
asked her to become his chief of staff
with the excellent Minister agree with
me that the person to be criticized here
today is the leader of the opposition
minister
I uh I concur but there are I I fear
that the um the leader of the opposition
in making this uh appointment perhaps
didn't realize perhaps blundered in his
approach I didn't really think through
the consequences of having someone right
at the heart of government being invited
to take up a position in the heart of
the labor party shifting from an
incredibly important as my honorable
friend mentioned very important work on
going to them working in a more party
political guys that also has
implications
hey Anderson thank you Mr speaker now
then this latest Ruby scandal from the
labor party has cast a dark staying on
Democracy so does my right honorable
friend agree with me that the leader of
the opposition should come out of hiding
come clean and publish the details of
the meetings
[Applause]
yeah I I
um there are
it's not a it is far from Beyond and
actually I've been pondering the
question asked by my uh right honorable
friend earlier I've been pondering the
uh the efficacy of people moving from
the Civil Service into uh apart from
parole so clearly that that can't be
deemed an impossibility there are roles
many of us have actually benefited from
time in this also says before then
taking on uh political uh roles but
there are ways of doing this and that is
what's so important and I think it's
it's absolutely would be really helpful
if the uh labor party could just
transparently set out exactly what took
place thank you Mr Speaker the house in
the country should know that on the 7th
of September 2019 I witnessed Sue gray
who is then permanent secretary for the
Department of Finance in Northern
Ireland discussed with the special
advisor to the UK cabinet office how to
exclude Solutions other than high
alignment with EU law and regulation
from consideration by the government in
respect to the north of Northern Ireland
as under the withdrawal agreement a
month later the government proposed the
northern protocol which subjected
Northern Ireland to EU law and
regulation since then sue gray has been
the civil servant specifically
responsible for advising on the union
considerations in government it was
reported this week that Sue gray was
present in the briefing of cabinet
ministers on the PM's Windsor framework
which among other things appears to
confirm and embed the application of EU
law and regulation
do you unscribed all right the question
is as I pulled up the member on the
other side once you go on and on there
must be a question and I've stopped it I
hope there's a question now
absolutely right
um don't judge me no no I'm just I'm
sorry sit down that's just
you just lost it completely no come on
thank you Mr Speaker the only saving
grace for colleagues in any honest fair
and unbiased investigation is the senior
civil service now in light of the
appointment of a senior civil servant by
Labor's leader who's been involved in
many investigations of colleagues would
my right honorable friend agree with me
but if the process looks like a rotting
stinking fish if it smells like a
rotting sleeping fish and it tastes like
a rotten stinking fish chances are it's
a rotten stinking fit let's go
my right-handed friend has expressed his
view in his own style uh he will know me
and my style to say I'm going to await
to the conclusions that come out of the
factual inquiry that we're going through
now but he has made this point as ever
Mr Speaker when I was a minister at the
department for leveling up I would have
had several conversations with Sue gray
on the basis of confidentiality and
impartiality I'm slightly unnerved to
feel that she may have simultaneously
been having discussions with the leader
of the opposition so I asked the
minister does is he able to tell us when
the Secretary of State the right and
remember for Surrey Heath became aware
of the negotiations between Sue gray and
the leader of the opposition
refers to conversations he was having
with uh Sue gray and Redman says that
he's not aware whether whether Sue gray
was having conversations with others at
the same time uh look
I'm not aware of any body and government
being informed before last Thursday of
those discussions but it could be easily
cleared up if the labor party was just
to publish the timeline this afternoon
Craig McKinley I believe in the
integrity and the diligence and the
value of our most unique Civil Service
all civil servants as everybody else has
got a right to a political view and they
can exercise that privately at The
Ballot Box I do want to put on record Mr
Speaker that I rigorously uh have
defended sugrair she did her work on
partygate last year but in this case
what is important is the job they've
left
the time in between and then the job
they then subsequently take up I don't
need to make the house aware that the
events of last year aren't just dust
that settled they're hanging thick in
the air still I'm asking on behalf of
the no no no you don't finish you're
finished no when I stand up means you
sit down and I hate to say we've both
been here a long time we should know the
rules of the homes no come and just have
the question without going to the euras
ask people not to venture into yes thank
you thank you Mr Speaker my apologies
I'm asking the question of the minister
from the men and women on the normal
Clapham Omnibus does this smell right
okay
very succinct and I would recommend the
uh honorable my honorable friend we do
need to get the facts out we do need to
know exactly what took place we are
doing that work it would help if the
labor party assisted Us in that process
Scott Benson Mr Speaker civil service
code states that officials must retain
the confidence of ministers as to their
political impartiality now that Sue gray
with knowledge of the most sensitive
details of government ministers has
agreed to work in a political capacity
for the leader of the labor party how
can the government ensure that other
ministers are protected from political
Stitch UPS minister
Mr Speaker I'm grateful to my honorable
friend uh I I will uh There are rules in
place as I've already said
there is a uh there is a means by which
uh civil servants who choose to leave
the world of the Civil Service and even
take on political roles can do it it's
just really important that we know and
ministers know that the rules are going
to be followed in those circumstances
and we need to know that they have uh in
this that is why we're looking as to
what took place and the lead body could
help us
thank you madam Deputy speaker
labor party has offered Sue gray the
role of Chief of Staff to the leader of
the opposition
this statement was issued by the labor
party on Thursday the 2nd of March 2023.
does my right honorable friend agree
with me that any reasonable person would
call into question the impartiality of
this person as of the 1st of March and
any day before
um
it's a fair question raised by my
honorable friend uh but it is one which
we need to explore given the questions
we are now asking about the timeline
towards uh the resignation of Sue gray
and as I've said repeatedly in this
place why the labor party can't just
tell us when the first meeting took
place when how long those meetings took
place for it might have been a very
short period of time it might be much
more don't compare the time but I think
we'd all be reassured to know they could
tell us this afternoon
Brendan Clark Smith
around 10 times this morning on LBC to
answer the actual question and listeners
will be questioning whether Mr rules
missed the rules
and I also note in today's Daily
Telegraph there's a piece from the
Constitutional expert sir Vernon bogdano
and I quote
the issue is important since if the
approach was made before publication the
hope of future employment might even if
only subconsciously have influenced its
content so it would not be possible to
longer regard sugray as an impartial
investigator does the minister agree
with me that perceptions matter yay
uh look I also read the article by uh
sir Vernon uh bognador he um he raised
interesting questions it is why we're
taking this so seriously and this is why
we are exploring we want to get to the
facts
uh Leone itchy thank you
not only impartiality is important but
also honesty and seeing as though the
leader of the opposition seemed a little
foggy somewhat to know about dates today
and it seems that perhaps the dates are
being scribbled on the back of a
fagpatic packet as we speak
um can if any dates are actually
declared to the minister could we
actually trust that there are accurate
the truth Minister well I understand
that the leader of the opposition may be
short of achieve a staff at the moment
but
I'm sure he's got someone who keeps an
eye on his diary I'm sure there is
someone who could inform uh this house
what the dates were when the meetings
took place where they took place and
what was discussed with whom is is not
too much to ask and it would help clear
up and it would save the leader of the
opposition from embarrassment about
being asked in things repeated occasions
and not being able to be clear
oh
maintaining complete political
impartiality is absolutely key to
maintaining credibility within the civil
service so does my right honorable
friend agree with me that surely if
there was even one meeting one
conversation which took place between
Sue gray and the labor party and the
leader of the opposition in advance of
her resignation about the job offer of
such a staunch hugely political natured
job then surely Sue Gray's political
impertiality in her role in the civil
service has to be brought into question
Minister I find my friend Madam Mr
Speaker the I set out in my response to
this uq uh the rules and they are in
there enhanced people can read through
them there are Protections in the rules
to try and ensure that uh impartiality
and perceived impartiality is not
jeopardized I I I we will explore
exactly what happened in these
circumstances things
uh Tom Randall
if you're in the commit and the debate
on the standards in public life in June
last year the honorable member for
Brighton Kent Town asked the deputy lead
the labor party to complain that um
sugary had been asked to attend before
the public administration across usually
Affairs committee uh but had been
refused several times to which the
deputy leader of the labor party replied
that she absolutely agreed with the
complaint and that it shows that the
Prime Minister had no regard for
transparency in that regard juice does
my honorable friend agree that to
actually leave the lane pass to live up
to the own standards which she was
extolling then and be transparent with
all the facts
minister
either the the the uh arrival lady says
we should follow the process and I agree
uh with the right honorable lady It's
always important to follow the correct
processes and I'm sure uh when the labor
party reveal all the datas I'm sure they
shall uh we will then be able to see
whether the processes were followed
thank you madam Deputy speaker in his
response to the sugary report on the
25th of May last year the leader of the
opposition said I have been clear what
leadership looks like I have not broken
any rules if he didn't if he didn't
consult a cobra before announcing this
requirement this appointment has he
still not broken any rules
I think I will conduct the analysis
first and then I'll be uh better
informed as to exactly what uh took
place uh but this could as I say be
cleared up by the lab party quite
swiftly
mark jenkinson thank you madam Deputy
speaker a woman of integrity and a
self-proclaimed Mr rules does my right
honorable friend agree with me that in
refusing to publish the timeline of the
meetings they've trust both of those
reputations
[Music]
speaker I think that's the case uh sadly
I think it is but it could easily be
changed by simple publication
Alexander Stafford
working my job center Plus in mortby and
dinnington who are horrified to hear on
LBC Radio this morning they leave the
opposition refuse to say 10 times when
when he'll contact the first by Sue gray
in connection with a political job does
the misagree with me if any contact took
place between the lead of the opposition
or the legal opposition or any members
labor party it calls into question not
only have current work and previous work
is done but in fact in partiality
unfortunately of the whole civil service
and we need to have the dates now the
meetings
minister
well I I I I I
respect the work done uh in the my
honorable friends constituency uh by uh
those hard-working civil servants and
right the way across the Civil Service
there is an absolute desire that they
retain their reputation for impartiality
uh which they all live in their daily
work and that's how they that is how
they work and they're determined to work
for uh work for ministers with a
relationship of trust that's incredibly
important there's not much we're asking
if the labor party just to produce that
schedule of dates the timeline and so
that we can start to put this hopefully
behind us with greater transparency Paul
Bristow thank you madam Deputy speaker
does the minister share my concern that
disappointment severely weakens trust in
our senior civil service and the light
that is inevitably now being shown on
Sue gray and her decisions by the media
such as the appointment of an advisor
who would advise all his Twitter
followers to join the labor party to the
public this looks farcical and as a
result only a full disclosure of
meetings and conversations will will
suffice in this grubby Affair yeah
Minister the the tragedy is that the
hard work of a uh of a public servant
over a long period of time is called
into question given the nature of the
process that we appears to have taken
place
um that is incredibly unfortunate but
the labor party can help fix that uh
they could just be a bit transparent
they could just be very open and they
could just say this is what actually
took place these are the dates this is
who met and this is where they were
speaker to be clear from my point of
view this is nothing to do with Sue gray
the lady could be our first living saint
for alaika it's the roles that she had
in government I can't think of a more
sensitive position than head of
propriety in ethics where you need trust
from the ministers it's not about this
party Southern labor MPS have been
sentenced to jail over the past 10 years
if they've been in government I think
she'd been quite busy with them too it's
about both sides and all parts of the
house being able to trust ministers and
I have to agree with colleagues the
trust is already broken you can't now
have a discussion with someone in that
position sure that they're not going to
cross over to the other side is it now
time we look at introducing regulations
to ensure this kind of thing can't
happen with such sensitive roles
okay stop
um speaker I I think the my older friend
uh if it's closing the session let me go
close on on the Note uh it's like it's
not about necessarily Sue gray and her
actions as I say she is a a public
servant who has for many decades worked
hard at the heart of government I think
it shows a miscalculation a misstep uh
by the leader of the opposition I think
in doing so I can only assume it was
inadvertent I have to hope it was
inadvertent but I think it has caused
more problems it is called into question
uh in some people's minds uh the
impartiality the perceived impartiality
of the Civil Service uh that was a
misstep it was a mistake he should
accept that in my view and he should
therefore be setting out uh through
transparency what happened when so that
we can then get absolute Clarity on what
took place
I thank
has just taken place
it is relevant and it's a point of
clarification I asked for because in
response to my question the minister
strongly implied
but the reason why the former
conservative member for abaconoi had
lost to be conservative whip was because
he has not consulted vacuuma but it's
not the case he lost the conservative
whip because he voted against the
government on a brexit vote
I assume the um The Honorable gentleman
is asking me to rule on something yeah
whether the minister would like to
clarify the point of order that you've
just raised Yes Minister thank you I'm
absolutely happy to uh to make a point
of clarification Madam Mr Speaker if
that was the impression I gave the
honorable gentleman to his question that
was not my intention whatsoever uh that
there was uh no disciplinary action
taken by the conservative party and
respect of that it was indeed a a brexit
uh voters the entrepreneurial world uh
we'll recall and I'm thanking him for
the opportunity to put that on the
record